Welchen Ursprung haben wir Menschen und wo
kommen wir her?
Fragen, die existentiell sind und doch bislang
in allen Details nicht eindeutig beantwortet
werden können.
Doch jetzt hat ein deutsches Forschungsteam
das Erbgut von zwei Neandertalern genauer
analysiert.
Das Besondere: Beide Individuen sind älter
sind als die bislang untersuchten Neandertaler.
Konnte dabei eine völlig neue - bisher unbekannte
- Neandertaler-Population aufgespürt werden?
Clixoom Sience & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
War es der moderne Mensch, also der Homo Sapiens,
der die Neandertaler verdrängt hat und letztendlich
dafür gesorgt hat, dass sich deren Spuren
vor etwa 40.000 Jahren verlieren?!
In der Fachwelt war man lange Zeit von genau
dieser These ausgegangen.
Doch neueste Genomanalysen zeichnen ein etwas
anderes Bild von unseren Urahnen.
Sie offenbaren, dass auch heute noch Elemente
des Neandertaler-Genoms in uns stecken.
Tatsächlich tragen wir Europäer rund zwei
Prozent Neandertaler-DNA in uns.
Heißt also im Klartext: Homo Sapiens und
Homo neanderthalensis sind nicht nur aufeinandergetroffen,
sondern sie haben auch gemeinsame Kinder gezeugt.
Demnach haben die modernen Menschen mit den
Neandertalern zusammengelebt und das Erbgut
hat sich vermischt.
Klar ist, dass die Neandertaler bei diesen
Gemeinschaften in der Unterzahl waren.
Doch wie wurde diese Zusammenleben gestaltet:
Handelte es sich vielleicht gar nicht um Sippschaften,
sondern um reine One-Night-Stands?!
Und was genau führt letztendlich zu dem Verschwinden
unserer Steinzeit-Cousins?!
Dazu gibt es viele verschiedene Theorien.
Wurden sie doch von unseren Vorfahren ausgerottet?
Oder war eine Massen-Epidemie der Grund für
ihr Verschwinden?
Auch ein Klimawechsel wird manchmal als eine
mögliche Ursache genannt.
Klar ist nur, dass ihr Verschwinden zeitgleich
mit der Ankunft des modernen Menschen - dem
Homo Sapiens - auf dem Kontinent zusammen
fiel.
Fachleute gehen zudem davon aus, dass die
Neandertaler zwar nicht mit einem Schlag ausgestorben
sind; dies jedoch innerhalb einer relativ
kurzen Zeitspanne von etwa 10.000 Jahren oder
weniger passierte.
Erst vor kurzem hatten wir hier bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction über eine super spannende
neue Erkenntnis in diesem Zusammenhang berichtet.
Ein französisches Forschungsteams hatte damals
herausgefunden, dass das das Aussterben dieser
Gattung dadurch begründet sein könnte, dass
die Fruchtbarkeitsrate bei den jungen Neandertalerinnen
über mehrere tausend Jahre hinweg leicht
zurückgegangen ist.
Laut der Fachleute passt dieser Erklärungsansatz
zu dem relativ kurzen Zeitraum ihres Aussterbens.
Demnach sei der Rückgang der Fruchtbarkeitsrate
zwar “sehr gering, aber er reicht über
einen langen Zeitraum, um den Neandertaler
aussterben zu lassen", so die Studie aus dem
Sommer 2019.
Die Fachleute spekulieren, ob dabei indirekt
auch die Ankunft der Homo Sapiens eine Rolle
gespielt haben könnten.
Denkbar sei es beispielsweise, dass unsere
Vorfahren Konkurrenten bei der Nahrungssuche
gewesen seien.
Die Aufnahme von weniger Kalorien kann nämlich
negative Einflüsse auf Schwangerschaften
haben.
Man mag es kaum glauben, aber trotz jahrelanger
und intensiver Forschung ist nicht nur das
Ende der Neandertaler ein riesiges Rätsel,
sondern auch deren Anfang!
Doch jetzt hat eine Forschungsgruppe vom Max-Planck-Institut
für evolutionäre Anthropologie in Leipzig
spannende Erkenntnisse zu unseren Steinzeit-Cousins
gewinnen können.
Die DNA-Analyse von zwei sehr alten Neandertaler-Individuen
lieferte nämlich Hinweise auf eine bisher
unbekannte Population, die vielleicht sogar
mit dem modernen Menschen verwandt ist.
Und noch mehr: Die neue Studie hilft auch
dabei, den Neandertaler als Spezies zu Beginn
seiner Entwicklung zu identifizieren.
Denn das ist alles andere als einfach.
Der Grund: Der Neandertaler ist unmittelbar
aus dem Homo heidelbergensis, seinem Vorfahren,
hervorgegangen.
Doch die genaue Grenzlinie zwischen diesen
beiden lässt sich kaum ziehen.
Die ältesten Funde, die sich eindeutig als
“klassischer” Neandertaler identifizieren
lassen, sind zwischen 120.000 und 130.000
Jahren alt.
Das Forschungsteam aus Leipzig hat sich jetzt
das Erbgut dieser sehr alten Neandertalern
vorgenommen.
Und zwar anhand der DNA von zwei verschiedenen
Individuen.
Zum einen haben die Fachleute Zellkern-DNA
aus dem Oberschenkelknochen eines männlichen
Neandertalers analysiert.
Dieser wurde 1937 in der Hohlenstein-Stadel-Höhle
in Baden-Württemberg aufgespürt.
Ebenso kümmerten sich die Fachleute um den
Oberkieferknochen eines Neandertaler-Mädchens,
das 1993 in Belgien gefunden wurde.
Beide sind älter als die meisten anderen
Neandertaler, die Forschungsteams weltweit
bislang untersucht haben: Die beiden Vertreter
dieser sehr alten Neandertalern lebten vor
etwa 120.000 Jahren.
Und das Ergebnis ist nicht nur eindeutig,
sondern auch überraschend: Denn diese frühen
Vertreter der Neandertaler aus Westeuropa
sind nämlich keineswegs eng mit den Neandertalern
verwandt, die zur selben Zeit in Sibirien
lebten.
Viel enger sind die beiden westeuropäischen
Neandertalern mit den letzten Vertretern ihrer
Spezies verwandt, die rund 80.000 Jahre später
in derselben Region wie sie lebten!
Dazu Kay Prüfer, der an der Studie beteiligt
war:” Das Ergebnis ist wirklich außergewöhnlich
und steht in starkem Kontrast zu der turbulenten
Evolutionsgeschichte des modernen Menschen,
die durch Austausch, Vermischung und Aussterben
von Populationen geprägt ist”.
Nach Ansicht der Fachleute legen die neuen
Ergebnisse nahe, dass die Neandertaler, die
vor rund 120.000 Jahren in Sibirien gelebt
haben, später dann durch eine europäische
Gruppe ersetzt worden ist.
Zudem vermutet das Experten-Team, dass es
eine bislang unbekannte Population an Neandertalern
gegeben haben könnte.
Frühe europäische Neandertaler könnten
von diesen DNA geerbt haben.
Denn die DNA-Analyse offenbarte, dass sich
das mitochondriale Erbgut des Neandertalers
aus der Höhle in Baden-Württemberg deutlich
von dem Erbgut der späteren Neanderthaler
aus derselben Region unterscheidet - ganz
anders also als das analysierte Erbgut aus
dem Zellkern.
Kurz zum Verständnis: Das mitochondriale
Erbgut vererbt sich mütterlicherseits.
Hinzu kommt, dass andere Forschungsteam bereits
vor einiger Zeit rund 70 Mutationen aufspüren
konnte.
Diese unterstreichen die Unterschiede zu bekannten
mitochondrialen Genomen anderer Neandertaler.
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: “Bei dieser
unbekannten Population könnte es sich entweder
um eine isolierte Neandertaler-Population
handeln, die noch nicht entdeckt wurde, oder
sie könnte von einer potenziell größeren
Population aus Afrika stammen, die mit dem
modernen Menschen verwandt ist”.
Die neue Studie liefert also nicht nur spannende
Erkenntnisse, sondern wirft gleichzeitig auch
neue Fragen auf.
Es bleibt also spannend!
Ungelöstes Rätsel: Wie starben die Neandertaler
aus?!
Anklicken, anschauen und Clixoom Science & Fiction
abonnieren und nicht die Glocke vergessen,
falls euch Wissenschaft interessiert.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.